um
i grew up in uh south jersey
a little beach town uh in jersey
with a large family
eight
kids and um
my dad had a dinner theater when i was
growing up so i i grew up on the stage
at a very young age
and i was uh doing great
in the first
out of the gate i guess
and uh right around 12 or 13
i was introduced to alcohol and um i
went from
here to
almost overnight
into uh into a whole nother i became a
whole another person actually
it took me about a year
to completely destroy everything that i
had uh that i had built and worked for
and whatever at that young age
and was basically
you know
going into high school and was uh ready
to quit and um and was over
um
you know parents and when to be home and
alcohol was was
it prov i don't i can't tell you the
the feeling i got when i
when i drank but it just it was the
answer and um
and so i decided i couldn't handle it
anymore i had to run away and so at that
time it was 1982 so i think
the
it was fort lauderdale was the big thing
and i was on the east coast and it was
caught kind of cold and so i was like at
a keg party and i grabbed my closest
buddy and i said let's go we're going to
fort lauderdale and i'm starting over
i'm getting out of this place
and uh and so you know we stole my dad's
cadillac and drove down to fort
lauderdale
at like you know
almost 14. i barely see over the
steering wheel and i was uh drunk as we
left and i remember coming to in
washington dc
the sun's coming up and i'm driving this
cadillac fleetwood and my buddies in the
car and i got like seven suitcases all
my my life's belongings and i'm trying
i'm like
and i'm like oh my god what did i just
do and i had this overwhelming sense of
sadness of just like i just left my
whole life
and i knew i couldn't turn back
and so i had to keep going and i just
was like you know well i did it and this
is it i gotta i gotta move on so i did
and we made it we went down to fort
lauderdale we made it down there
and uh
that didn't last long we we bumped into
somebody and
we shacked up for a couple days and uh
long story short our parents had tickets
for us waiting and we had to go back
home and they were just like okay we're
gonna pretend like nothing happened
and uh we're just gonna
you know move on and just
you know we don't know what you they
didn't know what to do they were like uh
so
um
yeah so at that point uh i lasted
another couple months and i just and i
said you know what i gotta go and i went
did the same thing and i went back to
fort lauderdale and it was getting ugly
and at that point
i wandered i ended up coming back to new
jersey and they the
long story short item went to treatment
a judge ordered media treatment center
to this place called white deer uh
white deer and in the mountains in
pennsylvania and it was uh man i went in
kicking and screaming i was like oh i'm
not an addict i'm not an alcoholic
and i was a you know a teenager and i
was you know i had earrings and and you
know shaved it i was a mess and
and uh and i had a breakthrough in when
i was in treatment and um
and i let go i said you know what all
right i i i admit i got a problem
and uh and i let go and at that point um
everything turned around and i had
spent the next
i had five or six years of sobriety
after that i
we ended up moving down to four to
florida actually
the family
um
and uh
i went into n a and a a and i was i had
uh i had a really good recovery actually
at a very young age and uh
was in and out of therapy and
and i was loving it and enjoying it
because i knew that if i didn't do that
that my answer was to completely rebel
and be a maniac so i kind of went the
other way and tried it a different route
and it was working and um
the only thing was is that i um
i
my
buddy of mine
in n a was going to california so we
threw him a going away party and
um
i ended up meeting a stripper
this is when i was junior in high school
down in florida and
i ended up moving in with her actually
when i when we came back from la and
my parents ended up moving back to new
jersey i stayed in florida and said
don't worry i'll finish high school down
here
and i you know i i didn't go back to
school
at that point except when i was senior
year
when everybody else was graduating again
i had this
flash in front of my eyes like oh my god
what am i doing
and so
i quick took a a
high school equivalency test and went
into
um junior college and then
and then i decided well what am i going
to do with my life so i i i like acting
and i i've been on the stage since
since i was 10 my dad had a dinner
theater and i was like you know what i'm
going to go to i'm going to study acting
i know that's not the best thing to
study at school but
i have to do something i like
so
um
i got a scholarship and went into uh
this great college in in winter park
florida and got my ba in in uh
in theater arts but that voice was right
there that that monkey was on my back
the whole time and it was senior year
and a senior week
and florida
and i was five years sober and just
thirsty and um
oh god
it took me a week out
the idea of i just remember thinking
about it
and i just
like
savored it for every day i was like i'm
going to do it i'm going to do it today
no no i'm not away and
man when i took that drink it was
it was
it's uh
that's that's
it's my nemesis it's what it's what i
have to uh to battle and it was so
powerful
and it was uh and i at that point i knew
that i was it wasn't going anywhere so i
just let it on and
i
i had a i got into a conservatory in new
york city uh for acting and so i went to
graduated college went to new york and
it's a two-year program
and then that first year i
oh it was great i was on broadway
um i was go studying
you know acting with
with some of the best teachers uh in new
york and um
al pacino was on the board of directors
and it was just great school great great
experience
but my head was so far up my ass i i had
i didn't even real you know here i am on
broadway going
you know
since i was a kid that's all i wanted to
do and i didn't even realize what i had
and
you know
you have to be asked back to the second
year and i remember the uh
i went to the the
to
the meeting with the president of the
school and he said
billy the teachers love you they say
they want you to come back but they're
they're not gonna they're leaving it up
to you and they they want you to uh make
the decision carefully and make sure
that you
come back if you come back that you come
back a hundred percent
and that you would know what that meant
and i and i know they they know they
could see me struggling you know we was
very intimate year because we were they
were in my business it was a very we
were studying characters and
you know going through it was it was
intense so they could see me struggling
with alcohol and drugs
um
and they didn't want me to
they wanted me to respect my art a
little bit more my craft and i
understood what they were talking about
because it it's not fair to to to do
that uh
and so i said uh let me think about it
for a couple weeks and i just and i
spent the next two weeks in a bar you
know
yeah you know i'm 21 years old and
22 and um
yeah and i went back to the president of
school i said yeah i think i have some
exploring to do i i'll uh i have to go
you know
discover some things and figure some
things out and in the back of my head
i'm saying that's all right i'll come
back to my dream my dream you know it's
no big deal and it really didn't set
set in
um didn't sink into what i had done
um
took about a year or two and then i
realized what
the power of drugs and alcohol at that
point had
compounded and more and more and more
and i realized how far gone i was and
what i had done
and
it's just like there's a couple there's
moments in life that are indelible where
you just kind of
where you get glimpses of them as you go
and it's like and that's one of those
moments where it's just like god
it was just really a sad moment like it
was just i couldn't touch it and it was
going it was it was gone and i knew that
and um
you know and so i
i
then i put on my seatbelt and i had uh
you know spent the next 10 12 years
until i was like 33
you know
drowning that that guilt
and beating myself up and
partying very as hard as i was a binge
binge drinker and party or so i just
would i would go on i would just go
until i couldn't stop
and then i would stop and then uh you
know just recover until i could walk
again get my sense about me and then go
back and dive into it again and it's
just like i just always had somebody
yelling at me like billy billy there was
always a girlfriend or a boss or
somebody trying to get me to i was late
oh you know it was just it was a mess
and i was tired and at 33 i was it was
back in florida again
and i was gonna kill myself i was like i
can't do this anymore and i was
i hit another bottom basically
and i s and i had
gotten sober with a friend of mine
she had remained sober the whole time
and she was out in california and i so i
called her and
she said come on out to california
and um i came out with like you know 20
bucks and um
and a lot of willingness and um
came out to this uh group called the
pacific group and it was a really strong
aa group and man
uh i
i grabbed it quick and um
i got a job pretty much like within the
next week
um i got a moved in with somebody
that needed a roommate uh within the
next week and then i got a car a couple
months later and i was working at i was
it was like within six months life was
completely different i was working out i
was down in venice beach you know you
know
working out and during this you know the
sunrise i got the pacific ocean you know
it was just like you know those moments
you know it was working out it's just
like god
where was i what i was can i kill myself
six months ago and here i am life is
completely
you know better and um it's turned and
it was good and i was
uh
you know uh but man the the the
addiction
the alcoholic the monkey it never leaves
and it never left and it was uh
it just
i
was
approaching my second year i was going
to get to my two-year medallion and
i kind of drifted away from the group a
little bit wasn't going to as many as
many meetings
and um my ex-girlfriend from florida
moved out here
um
which was a bad idea and that was the
start of uh falling back into some
patterns you know and i and i i was like
oh i can lean on that a little bit and i
guess and i
push you prepared myself for for a
relapse and i went out one weekend and
completely destroyed everything that i
worked for
uh
this two years here and and it man it
killed me um
i i was i walked around like as like a
zombie for a week
in hollywood like oh my god what did i
just do and i had no idea what i was
going to do and i knew that i
i wanted to die but i didn't have the
balls to kill myself
and i didn't really deep down i didn't
really want to die really because i've
had life's been good at sometimes and i
wanted it back i wanted to be back on
top i just
i wasn't willing to get sober uh and do
the right things to do it i guess um
[Music]
the right thing i guess at that point
would have been to have
to have
picked you know just dusted off and got
right back in and jumped right back in
but i couldn't do it i just couldn't do
it so it is what it is i i
i i knew that i couldn't do it i didn't
have the strength so i was a zombie and
then i bumped into a
this
you know crystal meth and i i hate to
say it but it was a godsend and i
believed it was at the time and i'm i
kind of you know i i don't know
help it you know it saved my life it
really did it i realized that i wasn't
it cured my depression immediately i
didn't want to kill myself anymore all
of a sudden
and um
and i was a mess of it when i drank i
was horrible i mean i was like i was the
guy you didn't want to be around that
came in you were like it was
it was like oh god this guy here he is
quick you know
hide
and
with meth it was different you know i
i you know i figured out how to
to you know behave correctly and and you
know made me actually responsible it was
strange the formula that i had been
looking for all the time all this time
was right there and i saw i i embraced
it and i you know of course here i am
you know shooting
uh
meth and i'm i'm praying as i'm
shootings you know with gratitude you
know it just didn't make sense
it was bittersweet um
i was using it
to
you know to
substitute and it worked uh i think the
best thing to have done would have been
to at maybe you know
whenever would you have been left that
alone and then got when i got strong
enough to get sober or
whatever not
maybe not sober but maybe move on to the
next phase but i didn't i let it and i
just kind of
man
you know here i am it's 2000 that was
2005.
uh and it's 20
21 22. oh my god so
it's been uh it's been over 20 years
that i've been you know
shooting shooting dope and and
you know i i
couldn't support myself
ever when i was um
you know using
drinking and doing drugs i always leaned
on you know a girlfriend or something
like that but when i
when i got on meth i i completely
changed and was you know i
you know it's it has a strange sexual
connotation to it and it it kind of
opened me up a little bit and i already
had a i was already very comfortable
around guys i grew up in the theater so
i was you know all my friends were
always gay and it was just like i felt
more or you know in the theater it's
just you it's just uh
it's not a gay thing it's just whatever
so
i realized that there was a lot of money
to be made especially
in la and i was right near west
hollywood and it was just like
craigslist was just starting up
it it was actually a really interesting
time
um and there was a there was a brief
period before the the psychos got on
craigslist and
uh that there it was actually really
really
cool
uh sight to get on to uh and meet people
um it just only lasts it was a brief
window but
and so i
was dealing drugs and i was and i was uh
you know and i was doing erotic massages
most of my clients were men some of them
were were couples and then there was an
occasional uh female
and uh i got a call one one uh one day
from this female and um
she was she gave me her address it was
up in laurel canyon and i was like oh
wow i'm so hungry for
for a female i was like i can't wait
can't wait so i get i went uh i met this
this girl and she was
she was beautiful
and
you know i moved in two weeks later
um
and
you know if she was not the right girl
to fall in love with i don't know what i
was falling alone i think it was
her situation that i fell in love with i
don't know but
it um
we had a very very uh intense uh
relationship for about nine months but
it was ugly it was really ugly and i
explored and
uh
you know
sides to myself and
parts of
sex and
it was just it was really crazy
um
she introduced me to something called
rough sex and
[Music]
and
believe it or not i was actually you
know very tame uh
up until that point and um
so the type of sex we were having was
was was really really uh rough she
wanted to be knocked out basically
and uh
and have to come too and kind of
you know figure out who's [ __ ] her
and and
what and whatever and that was her rush
she was a beautiful blonde girl who got
her way uh and so she got awful and she
wanted to be you know slapped and
and put in her place and that you know
and i was like so i found a happy medium
in there i i did it to where
you know it wasn't too much but to where
i felt comfortable and we
we had you know we were shooting dope
having rough sex and
you know
basically what happened was
is it ended um
with uh with me in jail and uh with four
charges on me
two counts of corporal injury
um false imprisonment and uh sodomy by
force
and uh
man that's another indelible moment
in the cop car going oh my god
what just
what is happening and i remember saying
to the officer i'm like
how long is it what's going and
they didn't even i mean i
if i hadn't known what was coming up i
don't think i would have been able to to
handle it but i was just moment by
moment at some point so here i am going
into the la county jail
with a sex charge and it's uh
not the place you want to be with the
sex charge they they by law have to
protect pedophiles but if you have a
regular sex charge they don't have to if
it's they're not obligated to protect
you
and but you're as good as done anyway
you know so it's like
so i was you know beat up immediately
when i when i got in and was like holy
[ __ ]
i'm still trying to get her out of my
system and trying to come true with what
just happened and i'm like i can't deal
with that so i was like
i was i was trying to have a nurse
breakdown i couldn't do it but
i was like so what do i do
so i figured out how to get into
solitary confinement for for 30 days and
i
you know
for a couple weeks i just cleansed
myself and and got my head right and got
her out of my head and just realized
that i needed to get back out in the
general population because it moved time
moved a lot faster and it was crawling
in that in that cell so
and i was
not going to have it so i got back out
in general population i just lied i
didn't
you know people asked me what i was in
here for i said domestic you know
domestic charge
and that was it and because it's not
like prison where they they
you know they know your business too
much because it's so transient you know
so you just lie and everybody else is
lying in there anyway they're all
lying so it's like so i was fine but i
spent 10 months in there uh first of all
they were off they said okay you can go
to prison for three and a half years
uh
and i was like three and a half years to
go to prison i'm not going to prison
there's no you know i i i didn't i'm not
guilty first of all of the charges that
you that you
have have on me i said
i'll admit i'm guilty of something but
not of these charges and so
here's if i had some money and i had an
attorney here's where our system is is
[ __ ] up if i had an attorney
i could have very easily have gotten
that reduced to a correct charge
which i gladly would have you know but
what happened was is
i ended up getting a state appointed
attorney the district attorney that was
fighting my case
was up for a judgeship in three months
so
you know it was i mean it was all bad
my my ex-girlfriend her dad is a
billionaire and a republican so
you know
i they put a million-dollar bail on me
um they had four charges if i was found
guilty of these four charges that was
going away for like 20 years
and i which was a death sentence and i
was like
man so i said well then you know what
we'll go to trial because there's just
no way you're going to be able to to
convince 12 people
that
that that's what i did there's
there's just no way and so we've
you know can postpone post post bapone
and uh finally
we get to trial and it was brutal man i
was in the in trial for like a two and a
half week trial and um
you know i completely i had to you know
let go
at that point really and i you know
found god again
and it's not like i felt was a jailhouse
thing because i i've had god in my life
um
always since i was a kid
it's just as i've grown up it's just
it's kind of evolved uh into my own
my own thing um
i've personalized a little bit more but
this was definitely another moment where
i let go and uh
and truly
you know
turned it over because i really had no
choice at that point you know
and so
long story short
they um
the trial ended in a hung jury on all
four charges
which was
i didn't know what it was i was like
what what is it hung jury what is it you
know i i didn't it was like i'm going
through all this the system is really
complicated
when you're going through it if you've
never been through it i'm like okay so a
hung jury i i know that
that's actually a good thing because it
means that they didn't they didn't
do what they set out to do which was to
put me away
but i didn't win
because i was and they refiled the case
all over again
and i was like oh my god so i just i i
was completely wiped out but i so i had
to go back two weeks later
at that point i was getting advice from
this old this old
black man who was he'd been through the
system and he was telling me what to do
and what to look for and he said you
know what he says don't worry they're
going to have a better offer for you now
because they have to they just spent all
that money and they didn't and they
didn't they didn't it didn't work so now
they have to give you a better deal
it's just part of the game and they did
they had a great a
better a great deal kind of
uh the
one thing i wanted was was to get out of
jail that's all i wanted
i could handle anything else that they
were giving me i just needed to get out
of jail because i was my life was being
threatened and i was dying in there and
so
um that was one of the one of the
options they said get out of jail but
uh also you sign a plea agreement that
says you're guilty and then five years
formal probation a year of sex offender
classes uh
and then register as a sex offender for
the rest of your life
and it
and my my attorney's going oh don't
you're not signing that you're not
saying that and i i said hell i'm not
i'm not going to trial with you again
either because
he was working with uh with the d.a and
giving her it was a horrible situation
so i signed and i plea agreement i got
out of jail
um and here i am it's 12 years it's been
about 12 years since that hap since i
got out
and man there's time again boom and uh
it's just that my drug addiction
uh
took on new you know i may i did the
five years formal probation
almost perfectly there was a small
little hiccup
uh and but thank god something was on my
side but
and then uh about three years ago my
mother died and so i added to
i was doing fine with the crystal meth
but the the the mom dying was a little
much for me and uh so i
i
brought on heroin
um to to just numb out and to not feel
and um
you know what it worked it really worked
um
you know as much as it could
until you know so here i am now and
um
and i'm i'm at a point where i've
done
everything that i that i shouldn't have
done and and
my life is uh i i can't if i want a
better life i know that i have to
i have to uh to leave
drugs and alcohol behind and i'm i'm
finally at a point where i want to do
that um and so
now the challenge has been has been
trying to get into a
detox um
and it's it's kind of
it's it's kind of challenging actually
i'm ready now and it's like
you know there's a waiting list in some
places and then medicality some places
don't take this and so it's like
gosh
[Music]
so i've been you know the past couple
weeks i've been trying to get into it
and do a detox basically um
and
um you know so i hope i didn't glamorize
that too too much but
you know the main thing is is that you
know i paid
for
you know all
looking back at
my life there's times when i say god i
wish i could have i should have
done something different but you know
i i
i did what i did because i i didn't have
a i believed that i didn't have a choice
so
of course i would i regret leaving new
york and leaving
school
but
i left because i didn't that voice
that alcoholic voice was so loud
that i didn't really believe that i had
a choice
so
it's kind of like
you know
that's what i was dealing with a lot of
times you know
and
you know i
if i had to do it overgrown i'd do it
differently of course because just for
the sake of having a different
experience
because the one that i chose was was
really
man i'm tired i'm really tired
and um
and i know that anything that's coming
up is not as nearly as going to be as
tough as what i've the
the path that i've carved out for myself
has been brutal so
sobriety is is really not that
not that hard i mean it is showing up
and being responsible is one of my
biggest fears
but
when you really break it down it's
it's so much
simpler and
joyous and gratifying compared to a life
of drugs and alcohol
i mean
i mean i just remember
when i was making that decision going i
was kind of excited like oh wow i've
gotta you know i get to go out and like
find myself you know and i was like oh
my god that's
what uh
horrible
you know that's that's what it it is
what it is
all right billy thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you good luck
with the detox yeah
very interesting thank you very much all
right thank you thanks
you